no I didn't and I didn't mislead the
house and I don't believe I'm guilty of
her content but I think that this
process happily will will vindicate me I
know it's been going for for a long time
I'm grateful to to the committee this is
remember what this is all about I think
people forget this is about whether when
I when I went into Parliament on the
first and I think the 8th of December
2021 and I said that guidance rules
regulation has been followed in uh in
number 10 I actually believed or
suspected at that time or knew that
um there'd been events that that broke
the rules
and I didn't I believe that what we were
doing was within the rules and that's
what I why I said what I said to
Parliament and I think what's so
interesting about the report today is
that after 10 months of of effort and
sifting through all the uh the
innumerable whatsapps uh and messages
um they found absolutely no evidence to
suggest otherwise and there's absolutely
nothing to show that any advisor of mine
or a civil servant told me warn me in
advance that an event might be uh
against the rules nothing to say that
afterwards they thought it was against
the rules nothing just to show that
um I myself uh believed or was worried
that something was against the rule so
that fat family is a pretty astonishing
Gap given the huge amount of stuff that
they have and you know given also
frankly that not all the the testimony
that they have comes from uh people who
are necessarily on my on my side as it
were and so
I just want to want to repeat uh the
reason there's that Gap the reason
there's no evidence to show that I must
have known right I must have believed
that uh illegal events were taking place
is because I didn't and I thought we
were fighting covid to the best of our
ability in very difficult circumstances
in number 10 in the cabinet office uh
night and day and I believe that what we
were doing was in Conformity with the
the covid regulation so that is what why
I said what I said in in Parliament and
uh that's why I don't think I'm certain
there's been no contempt there are
photographs in the report of you in
rooms with people who are not socially
distanced in rooms with booze on the
table the committee says
that it would have been obvious to you
at the time that these were breaches of
the guidance and that because you hadn't
mentioned these events that you were at
to the house that may be how you've
misled yeah but you see and of course
people will say oh it must do you must
be it must be obvious to you that uh
something was uh was awry and and so on
you've got to remember what it's like
being being prime minister you are you
you do what your civil servants uh
advise you to do instruct you to do you
you moved from one event to the next you
have a massively regimented diary uh
there were a number of events as
everybody everybody knows uh where I uh
went very briefly to say thank you to
staff and and that and that kind of
thing but I believed implicitly that
these events were within the rules nor
did anybody tell me before or afterwards
anything to the to the country and you
know I just
just imagine sorry can I just speak here
when you say before or after the report
has got whatsapps in it from your
director of communication saying things
like I'm struggling to to see how this
was within the rules that this blows
another hole in your account but I I and
he's talking about an event in the
cabinet room uh in in June of 2020 where
actually you know we were we were so
confident that it was totally above
board that we uh we we we you know that
the one that I was five I continue to
apologize for we actually put it in the
in the newspapers we read it I didn't
read that but somebody read it out and
um I never thought that that was against
the rules and nobody told me uh before
or or afterwards that it was uh that it
was you know against rules I was very
very surprised just just imagine
that um
I had I had genuinely thought
that stuff was going on in number 10.
that was covered rule breaking
and everybody will understand
the implications of that if I'd known
that everyone understand the
implications of that for the government
for ability to to fight kovid what a
story that would be you would expect me
in in order to have immediately
communicated something
to my closest advisors and officials
saying what is this what is this problem
we've got here with this this event what
do we do after doing about it there's
nothing at all to show that why not
because I believed that what we were
doing was and implicitly within the
rules and that's why I said what I said
in the House of Commons and that and
that is why
I think you know thank the committee for
their for their labors and and
um you know I'm sorry it's all been
going on for so long but there's been no
contempt here
and one more just if I may at that point
before you stood up in the Commons and
said quite definitively the students the
best of your knowledge there was there
had been no the the covert guidelines
were followed at all times did you stop
at any point and think back to those
events you were at and think actually
did that no uh so so what is no what I
what I because you didn't consider it at
all no because what I what I what I we
the thing we were discussing was an
event that I actually hadn't been at
this was the story that that uh that
came that came in and uh there were and
there were some questions about from the
from the about other events but I I
believed implicitly that they were
within the rules and
um
that was why I was so confident and you
get another point if I
that
you know if I thought it was
um a good idea to go into into
dispatch box in front of all my peers
all my colleagues and say that uh events
that there were no rule breaking events
in in number 10. when I knew or cabinet
office when I knew that that could
probably be contradicted by dozens and
dozens of officials why why on Earth
would I would I have done that it simply
it doesn't make sense I believe that
what we were doing was uh within the
rules that's what I said that's why I
said what I said in
um in the chamber Uh I that it was my
honest belief at the time and that's why
you know I thank the committee for the
labors but I really don't think there
has been a contempt here I will add one
one um
codisil if I can and that is I do I do
think it is a peculiarity let me put it
that way that the person who conducted
the inquiry into uh what went on in
number 10 and and the cabinet offers who
was presented to me as a person of uh
complete political uh impartiality with
absolutely no political apps to Grime
whatever has just been appointed the uh
the chief of staff of the leader of the
labor party I mean I I make no comment
about it except to say that I'm sure
people you know may want to draw their
own conclusions about the confidence
they can place in her inquiry
motives behind her the way she conducted
her inquiry and and to
um into her report I think you know
people I think how can I put this in the
most uh in the most restricted I think
people may look at it in a different
light
Austria you were satisfied that it was a
wholly independent report isn't that
isn't that a real it's quite something
isn't it it's a question as civil
servants ability to put their own
political feelings aside and not be
neutral I think it's a question isn't it
uh look as I say people will make up
their own minds about this and I think
that uh I if you told me at the time I
um commissioned Sue gray to do the
inquiry if you told me all the stuff
that I know no
um I think I might have
cross-examined her more closely about
her independence and uh I might have
thought about whether she was whether or
I might have asked I might have invited
him into this way I might have invited
her to reflect on whether she was really
the the right person to do it and some
of your colleagues have suggested that
this discredits her reports
the key point that I want to go never
mind would you tell them that that's not
never mind never mind never mind sugray
and never mind sugray the keep the key
point for me is is today that
um you know people will draw their own
conclusions
the the key thing for me is that today
after a lot of of Labor
um and I before which I thank them uh
the select committee her produced date
or the Privileges can be I should say
have produced a report which uh
I believe totally vindicates me because
there is no evidence uh whatever that
when I stood up in Parliament I said
anything that I did not believe and
therefore there is no no contempt